Speaker 1: President Joe Biden has tested
positive for COVID 19. He has reportedly had
very mild symptoms up until this point in time. Is
fully vaccinated. Has received two COVID booster
shots. And according to Karine Jean-Pierre, the
current press secretary, is experiencing very
mild symptoms. There is very little additional
information right now. You now know everything
that I know. It is not clear whether there has
been contact tracing done or whether that's even
relevant at this point. Joe Biden is around a lot
of different people all the time that you will
remember that failed former president Donald Trump
also experiencing COVID 19 during his presidency.
With Trump, it was so serious that he actually
was advised to get to Walter Reed Medical Center
by helicopter sooner than later for fear that
he may not be able to do so under his own power
if they waited and his disease progressed. Donald
Trump had trouble breathing and it was a serious
case of COVID. And Joe Biden is even older than
Donald Trump. Older than Trump now, an older than
Trump was at the time that he had COVID. So we
wish him the best. We don't know of any reason
at this point that Joe Biden would be unable to
discharge his duty as president of the United
States, turning over power to the vice president,
Kamala Harris. But we are going to watch it. That
is the information we have as of right now. And
within within hours, there indeed may be more.